entsetzen und trauer in hanau bei einem
schweren gewaltverbrechen sind in der
hessischen stadt neun menschen getötet
worden
später entdeckte die polizei die leiche
des mutmaßlichen täters in einer wohnung
und dazu eine weitere tote person
[Musik]
mein mitarbeiter weiter alle tot dass
jemand mit waffen gekommen hatte
[Musik]
wir haben keine informationen was
passiert in dieser nacht
[Musik]
doch nur
wir halten zusammen und wir werden uns
verteidigen
die leute haben angst die leute sind
wütend traurig weil alle sich fragen was
kommt als nächstes wird es am 6
[Musik]
willi viorel war ihr einziger sohn 22
jahre alt ist er geworden
er sei so glücklich mit seiner freundin
gewesen sagen seine eltern und mit
seiner arbeit in einem
logistikunternehmen julia baron und ihr
mann niculescu sind immer noch in tiefer
trauer könne es oft nicht begreifen dass
ihr kind ermordet wurde
wir sind ganz alleine
ich kann das nichts ausmachen
wir warten immer darauf dass unser willi
nach hause kommt aber er kommt nicht
mehr
uns geht es sehr schlecht
[Musik]
julia und niculescu sind vor einem monat
in die neue wohnung gezogen
in der alten hatten sie zusammen mit
willi gelebt nach seinem tod haben sie
es dort nicht mehr ausgehalten
das paar zieht uns dass sie noch etwas
anderes quält niculescu zeigt uns das
handy von willi dass sie von der polizei
zurück bekommen haben
dadurch erfuhren sie dass ihr sohn den
täter tobias er gesehen hat als der nach
den ersten schüssen in der shisha bar
zum nächsten tatort fahren wollte hinter
verfolgt hat viel mark telefoniert zum
polizei war und keine antwort von
polizei und das verstehen das nicht
hätte ihr sohn willi überleben hätten
weitere morde verhindert werden können
diese fragen stellen sich die beiden und
dann zeigen sie uns das auto von willi
dass sie vor kurzem von der polizei
zurück bekommen haben mit den
einschusslöchern aus der tatnacht
insgesamt feuerte der terrorist tobias
er mindestens sechs schüsse auf willi ab
willi verfolgte den täter
der bemerkte ihn und tötete ihn mit
einem kopfschuss durch die
windschutzscheibe seines mercedes in
diesem video einer überwachungskamera
vom tattag ist oben rechts willis auto
zu sehen
der täter tobias r rennt an ihm vorbei
willi fährt mit seinem auto zurück nimmt
die verfolgung auf
bis zum zweiten tatort im hanauer
stadtteil kesselstadt in der arena bar
und dem angrenzenden kiosk erschoss
tobias er weitere menschen
willi wird von der polizei tot in seinem
auto auf dem parkplatz gefunden
seine eltern erfuhren am nächsten mittag
dass er sohn ermordet worden war
warum ist das passiert was passiert
rund drei monate nach dem terroranschlag
in hanau erinnern viele orte in der
stadt an die neuen jungen menschen die
von einem rassistischen terroristen
ermordet wurden
auch an den verschiedenen tatorten wie
vor der shisha bar heumarkt und der rena
pa in kesselstadt
[Musik]
tot sind wir erst wenn man uns vergisst
hatte fährt und war vor seinem tod auf
facebook geschrieben als hätte er etwas
geahnt
es ist zum leitspruch für viele hier
geworden
keiner soll sie vergessen in der
innenstadt hat die initiative
neunzehnter februar eine neue
begegnungsstätte eröffnet hier kommen
auch angehörige zusammen können ihre
fragen stellen finden beistand verraten
was mutters apple ist oft hier
sie können immer noch nicht arbeiten
erzählt sie uns die trauer sei immer
noch zu groß tausende warum in meinem
kopf ich wollte einfach sehr viel
erzählt uns dass sie damals kurz nach
den schüssen zur arena bargeld war
denn sie wusste dass ihr sohn fährt hat
an diesem abend mit seinen freunden dort
war sie habe polizisten sein foto
gezeigt aber die hätten gesagt er sei
nicht drin
ich 36 morgens haben wir da gewartet und
ich dachte mein sohn ist verletze ich
sehe im krankenhaus aber er war da
wusste ich eine idee war da
ceplak vor allem die ungewissheit ob
fährt leiden musste
nachdem er von tobias er angeschossen
wurde denn während der todeszeitpunkt
bei allen anderen getöteten bis
mitternacht war stand in verrats
sterbeurkunde 13-mal großer schock für
mich wirklich ganz groß und ich weiß
nicht warum
weil ich dachte er ist sofort tot er war
sofort tot
und war eine und ich habe immer noch
keine antwort grund ja ich habe ja
selber angst von antwort ich große angst
ich denke mir bei mir liegt da und er
ist sehr verletzt und keine kopien wenn
so ist ja ich habe große angst sehr viel
team ist unwahr fordert eine lückenlose
aufklärung der tat die ihr leben ins
wanken gebracht hat
genauso wie der vater von zeiten ist
chemie auch er kommt regelmäßig in die
begegnungsstätte um zu reden und zu
trauern
sein sohn zeitmesser wurde 21 jahre alt
hatte maschinen und anlagenführer
gelernt wollte eine weiterbildung zum
techniker machen
er starb bei dem anschlag sein anderer
sohn zeit etwas wurde von tobias er
angeschossen und schwer verletzt
die schulter in hans aber auch getroffen
ich hatte ganz schlafen ganze macht
also laufen seien ganze wohnung
wir schlafen auch nicht und das war
unserer leben nehmen und wie die kleine
kinder fragt uns immer wir können nicht
das ab und geben das uns sehr schwierig
haschemi beklagt dass er noch immer
nicht das handy seines sohnes von der
polizei zurück bekommen hat und über die
ermittlungen würden sie alle nur wenig
erfahren hat die polizei zum beispiel
bei dem einsatz am 19
februar zu zögerlich reagiert solche und
andere vorwürfe verbreiten sich unter
den angehörigen wir können nicht einfach
sagen ja die polizei schuld oder so aber
der muss auch seine arbeit machen wenn
wir vertrauen die polizei und der sollen
das machen und das ist unser wunsch und
wir haben unsere kinder verloren
wer bist du mann gehört zu den
ehrenamtlichen mitarbeitern der
initiative neunzehnter februar genauso
wie hagen kopf sie alle versuchen
antworten auf solche fragen zu finden
und können viele zweifel verstehen aber
der polizeieinsatz gab es glaube ich und
so verstehe ich das auch von vielen
angehören viele betroffene betroffenen
totales versagen wie reagiert wurde
beziehungsweise wie nicht reagiert wurde
und natürlich damit auch verbunden wie
so ein rassist überhaupt waffen besitzen
kann der die behörden schon vorher
aufgefallen ist wieso kann er waffen
besitzen wieso wird auch noch seine
waffe seinen waffenschein auch noch
verlängert
diese und andere fragen beschäftigen
viele angehörige vor zwei wochen kamen
sie zum hessischen landtag die linke
hatte einen dringlichen berichtsantrag
gestellt und sie alle wollten mit hören
auch mir salam haschemi es gekommen mit
seiner frau und seiner tochter sei
genauso wie nico lescaut und julia bauer
sie hoffen dass sie mehr darüber
erfahren warum die polizei die anrufe
ihres sohnes willi nicht annahm
viele haben das gefühl vergessen worden
zu sein haben fragen und fühlen sich
damit im stich gelassen
auch emis kürbis die mutter von z
keine information aussage nichts nichts
nichts
bz wissen in einem separaten raum
konnten sie zu hören wie unter anderem
der hessische innenminister beugt und
der bundesanwalt auskunft geben
am ende sind die meisten aber enttäuscht
armin kultur wird kritisiert dass er
erst sehr spät nachdem sein sohn hamza
für tot erklärt wurde davon erfahren
habe aber es waren sechs stunden im
gebiet nicht ungewissheiten uns wurden
hoffnungen gemacht ist verletzt im
krankenhaus
und er war schon tot
man hat es doch gleich sagen und auch
die frage warum tobias er einen
waffenschein hatte blieb unbeantwortet
ja
er war nicht so gelaufen wie kann man so
einen mackenstein geben
der bruder von göttern gültigen
kritisiert dass im zwischenbericht von
einem einzeltäter und mutmaßlich keinen
mit bis an die rede sei es gibt auch
niemanden wo wir jetzt hinterfragen
können wir haben uns
also auf deutsch gesagt
und julia und ihr mann haben sie mehr
darüber erfahren warum ihr sohn billy
sterben musste
wir spielen nicht zufrieden wie zufügen
wir haben keine information was passiert
in dieser nacht in dieser nacht am 19
februar 2020 als der bekennende neonazi
tobias r
neun junge menschen und später auch
seine mutter und sich selbst tötete
es gab viele augenzeugen
er war eben die schießerei vor meiner
türe mitleid war dass jemand waffen
gekommen hat
dieses foto der überwachungskamera in
der bar la botte zeigt den moment als
tobias er seinen ersten mord in dieser
nacht begeht er erschießt carlo jan
welker der hinter der theke arbeitet
der 33-jährige gebürtige bulgare
hinterlässt seine frau und einen
siebenjährigen sohn
in diesem video verkündete tobias er
seine wirren botschaften für die
hintergründe zu ihm und seiner
rechtsradikalen tat ist der
generalbundesanwalt zuständig und
verweist auf die laufenden ermittlungen
doch viele angehörige haben auch fragen
zum polizeieinsatz am 19 februar
deswegen verabreden wir uns mit
polizeihauptkommissar henry faltin monat
besucht hier mal die polizei anzurufen
warum hat die politik reagiert in der
nacht haben sehr viele menschen
angerufen
das heißt wir haben die information über
den sachverhalt bekommen und das ist
auch wichtig besonders wichtig dass wir
1 leiden bekommen aber es wird technisch
einfach gar nicht machbar sein dass alle
menschen durch kommen und so erklärt
sich auch dass viele anrufen und die
polizei da nicht erreicht haben und ist
aber war will ihn so dass er ja einer
der ersten war um 21 56 da können gar
nicht so viele anrufe eingegangen sein
weil das ja erst passiert ist und hier
kann es dann sein dass man eben in der
schleife eben gerade besetzt hat ist
deswegen tragisch weil jetzt klar ist
dass wir nicht in einer sicher war
ermordet wurde sondern den täter
verfolgt hat da versucht hat die polizei
zu erreichen ist das jetzt teil der
ermittlungen auch dass man sagt
eventuell hätte er überleben eventuell
hätte man weitere morde verhindern
können alles was dazu beiträgt den
gesamt sachverhalt zu erklären wird
natürlich teil der ermittlungen auch
werden jetzt zum fall hat unwahr
die mutter hat gesagt der todeszeitpunkt
war drei uhr nachts die schüsse waren 22
uhr was war in der zwischenzeit warum
konnte sie nicht zu ihrem sohn was hat
die polizei in dieser zeit gemacht wir
könnten da den unmut der hinterbliebenen
verstehen dass es eine tragische sache
wie wir sie noch nie zuvor erlebt haben
da gibt es natürlich ganz große
verschiedene interessen von den
angehörigen die schnell zu ihren lieben
zu ihren diese fürchten dort vielleicht
verstorbenen zu gelangen aber es klingt
sehr kalt von seiten der polizei
wir müssen unsere sperrzonen einhalten
und dann bestätigt uns henry faltin
einen vorfall von 2017 ein getarnter
mann rannte mit sturmgewehren des
jugendzentrum in kesselstadt bedrohte
jugendliche und floh
die täterbeschreibung von zeugen passte
auf tobias r der in der nähe wohnte
warum wurden damals nach den abzügen
aussagen keine ermittlungen aufgenommen
dieser vorfall wird teil der ermittlung
also von daher bitte ich um verständnis
dass wir dazu kann außer waren viele
fragen bleiben erstmal offen
vor allem für die angehörigen der opfer
quälen sie fühlen sich allein gelassen
bis anfang märz sei das anders gewesen
sagen viele
damals kamen zur zentralen trauerfeier
in hanau hochrangige politiker darunter
bundeskanzlerin merkel und
bundespräsident steinmeier gemeinsam
legten sie mit den angehörigen blumen
nieder
auch sehr viel themis unwahr gedachte
ihren sohn fährt hat
zu den rednern an diesem abend gehörte
auch kemal kocak in seinem kiosk in
hanau starben drei seiner freunde
diese menschen kamen jeden tag ist schon
was zu kaufen sondern um hallo zu sagen
und mich zum armen oder ist sie zu
umarmen
jetzt sind die alle nicht mehr da ich
möchte von meiner seite aus nicht mehr
viele genauso die angehörigen nicht mehr
viele wörter hören sondern wir wollen
taten sehen
cage hat gehörte zu den ersten
betroffenen die wir nach dem terror am
19 februar interviewten abgesehen fünf
sechs leute liegen auf dem boden zwei
hinter der theke 2 also alles total
blutbad war meine batterie ein
mitarbeiter arbeitet dann alles tut
seinen kiosk in dem alles geschah hat
kemal kocak aufgegeben
diesen hier in der nähe des hanauer
heumarkt führt der 46 jährige weiter
er ist immer noch oft sehr traurig
trauert um seine freunde und ist auch
enttäuscht uns geht es immer noch wie am
selben tag und beschäftigt ganz
natürlich ist ja nichts passiert nachdem
tat was zugunsten uns ist zumindest
diese tat muss auch geklärt werden das
ist immer noch im dunkeln alles wir
haben ja nichts mehr gehört
nachdem diese tat passiert ist gab es
eine trauerfeier und nach dem taucher
ist eisen stille kämmerlein kocak sagt
dass ihm am anfang hilfe in aussicht
gestellt worden sei vor allem wegen
seines kiosks den er aufgeben musste
doch nicht nur die finanzielle
unterstützung sei ausgeblieben dass sie
uns seelisch moralisch unterstützen das
ist nicht passiert
wir wurden alleingelassen wir sind
alleine
wir leben immer noch in angst und wir
sind uns nicht sicher hier jeder der
hier reinkommt wissen wir nicht ob
dessen freunde sondern feind ist ja das
kann ja jeder minute jederzeit wieder
passieren alles kemal kann nicht
vergessen dass er seine freunde tot
aufgefunden hat beinahe hätte auch
weitere angehörige verloren
tobias er war damals auch in diesem
chaos gestürmt sein sohn und krusa
seinem lagerraum gewesen
dort hörten sie den gong dass jemand
reinkommt kurz raus also nicht ganz die
tür aufgemacht draußen haben gesehen
dass der vorstand mit einer waffe das
waren sekunden teile der ist rein und
hat coop links rechts ist keiner weise
wieder raus krantz werden die hier an
der theke eine kasse kann man sich
vorstellen wie viele tote auch hier an
die angehörigen der opfer sind seit dem
terror vom 19 februar zusammen gewachsen
treffen sich immer wieder um den neuen
getöteten zu gedenken und lassen weiße
tauben fliegen an ihren geburtstagen wie
hier von pädagogisch der 30 jahre alt
geworden wäre
der dekan organisiert mit seinen
mitarbeitern viele solche treffen und
beklagt die mangelnde psychologische
betreuung bis heute nach so einem
erlebnis hätte eigentlich in
seelsorgerische unterstützung direkt auf
dich zukommen müssen also telefonisch
kontakt treten und daneben auch
hausbesuche oder so das hat ja nicht so
wirklich stattgefunden
sie alle fordern dass der rassistische
terroranschlag von hanau lückenlos
aufgeklärt wird wollen gewissheit ob man
die morde hätte verhindern können
vor allem aber geht es ihnen darum dass
sie vielen unschuldigen opfer niemals
vergessen werden
[Musik]